[Musique]
dans le fond ils viennent comme
l'exproprier mentalement
bon c'est pour préciser le milieu
agricole
des terres agricoles de grande qualité
progressivement envahi par le
développement domiciliaire
le phénomène est bien connu souvent
décrié et pourtant il continue ici la
division entre développeurs et
agriculteurs est plus forte que jamais
le passage du temps n'a rien résolu
après l'échec de l'aventuré
aéroportuaire l'arrivée massive des
banlieusards et d industrie qui accentue
le choc entre deux mondes un défi
emblématique
on est sur le terrain que la ville mort
être oubliée pour faire éventuellement
un parking pour la dent andré lapointe
producteurs de lait et céréales héritier
du savoir-faire de son père et de son
grand père se bat contre le projet de
gare comme un gaulois contre
l'envahisseur depuis plus de dix ans il
constate maintenant qu'il est en train
de perdre sa bataille lors de chaque
côté gauche ils vivent d'agriculture on
est avait d'atteindre la 55me de
population on aimait mes unités de
logements par année
alors mes unités fois 2.5 par femme il
s'est tout de même 2502 population année
un prêt unique vient de s'établir dans
la région les élus municipaux de la
région de mirabel réclame cette gare
depuis 2005 le maire actuel est confiant
de l'obtenir sous peu notre population
revendique ce service là depuis une
décennie et nous mais nous avons mis les
efforts nécessaires
et heureusement même le gouvernement
précédent elle avait accordé
donc on n'ose croire d'ici 2019 même les
travaux débuteront le projet retenu
prévoit l'aménagement de vastes terrains
de stationnement et d'un quai
d'embarquement au milieu d'une zone
agricole protégée
c'est clair que dans le contexte
métropolitain cautionne une gare en zone
agricole c'est l'ancien message dans la
mesure où le plan d'aménagement
métropolitaine où dit il faut dorénavant
condense suis auto des points d'accès
aux transports collectifs
donc je vois mal le lendemain de mirabel
ne pas se servait de ce dossier là pour
écouter soyez conséquente et donc on
ouvre la porte à une demande de dézonage
de l'autre côté de la future gare la
production agricole est intense ces
jours ci depuis vingt et un le secteur
ici a beaucoup changé
stéphane lapointe tente de sauver sa
récolte de maïs malgré les chutes de
neige prématurées
il souhaitait aussi ajouté un troisième
poulailler sur sa ferme il a choisi de
le construire ailleurs dans une zone
moins menacée par le développement
on peut plus investir en place ou ce que
peut-être dans 20 ans ce propos étaient
du doigt qu'on est de trop juste le
trafic le soir et matin ici l'eau pour
choisir nos erreurs pour se promener
entre acteurs dans le show mais c'est
pas la route est pas conçu pour recevoir
un flot de véhicules
abstenez mais je tente humide qui est
mis en place
ensuite vont être contents legault qui
voit le maire de biens rabel réclament
aussi l'élargissement d'une autoroute
est le prolongement de deux autres pour
atténuer la congestion automobile aux
heures de pointe
le nouveau premier ministre françois
legault a déjà promis de le faire dans
la grande région de montréal
faut pas non plus penser qu'on
construire plus de routes non on a quand
même une population qui s'attendent à ce
qu'on puisse
bon faciliter la mobilité alors à
mirabel exemple 97% zoné agricole
alors on n'investira pas sur des des
montant colossal d'autobus de trajets
d'autobus pour desservir bon des
secteurs qui ne sont pas nécessairement
important c'est une mauvaise nouvelle
pour l'environnement et pour la survie
du territoire agricole croit gérard
beaudet parce que l'étalement urbain
favorise même localement
l'utilisation accrue de l'automobile
c'est ce qu'on nous dit depuis 50 ans
que les problèmes automobile on va les
régler jusqu'à maintenant la solution là
pour trouver les diverses tentatives
nord-américaine de création de services
de proximité dans les banlieues n'ont
jamais permis de réduire l'utilisation
de l'automobile fait remarquer le
professeur beaudet le problème c'est
qu'à partir mon taxi dans son automobile
on se déplace en automobile on n'ira pas
faire une partie de ses emplettes aux
petits commerces du coin
ensuite retourné à la maison prendre
soin automobile allait compléter nos
emplettes dans un méga sont dans un
power center par exemple
mais les agriculteurs de la région ne
lâche pas prise et avis au gouvernement
legault ils n'ont pas l'intention de le
faire de si tôt c'est à dire lolo ne
m'appartiennent pas y appartiennent aux
autres générations propose un avant goût
et puis je vais laisser à ma relève avec
moi je ne suis que de passage se parle
depuis l'argent là c'est ça aucune
valeur vos sujets
[Musique]
on les nourrit une tape dessus vous
sentez comment s'en sortent des savants
à ce qu'on devrait être on devrait être
protégé enfin photo se bat pour
continuer à l'ignorer
[Musique]